tristan mckenzie who's making his fourth
start two out of the first three's had
very good location
blew it right by him
and sticks mckenzie sets him down one
two three
in the first santana with a couple hits
last night hopefully he's going to start
getting going from this side of the
plate
he drills that one a long way and it's
not coming back deep into the bullpen
and the indians will play from in front
as they strike in the first on a two out
two run homer well he came right back
and i'll tell you what he put a great
swing on that ball and he hit it a ton
so indians will play from in front and
once again kansas city falls behind
early matt reynolds in his
first opportunity here with kansas city
swinging a miss he goes down swinging
and the inning is over
tristan mckenzie sharp through two
scoreless
sandy leone liftoff high in the air deep
right center field this baby is going
going gone
his second home run of the year and it's
three to nothing cleveland
that snaps an oh for ten slump for leon
did you see lindor's eyes wow
that was some serious power from sandy
leone
edward olivares and with four games in
kansas city he's going seven out of 18
and the payoff pitch
swung on and missed just challenged him
with a heater and blew it right past him
at 94. the royals have two on with one
out and merrifield coming up
fastball is crushed to left field and
whitmerfield hits a three-run home run
and ties the game
oh yes take that ball
there you go
oh that's a beautiful thing
then you know it's gone way to go with
that's the way the power went out of
here eighth on the year it's the most
runs mckenzie's allowed now in a start
team of one against the tigers his first
timeout two to saint louis
odyssey is out looking two down shut out
these royals for six innings last time
he faced him
strikes him out so he fans three in the
inning
but when merrifield hits a three-run
homer now the set now the 1-1
swung on hit high hit deep to right
field it's got a chance it is gone
francisco lindor
with a two-run homer to right
the indians third of the night and the
indians now back on top five to three
as frankie lindor gets his seventh home
run
and frankie lindor puts the indians
right back on top
five to three
now matt reynolds
there's a called third strike to matt
reynolds
here's the one-two pitch
waved at and missed strike three put
another one on the board for tristan
mckenzie tristan mckenzie leaves the
game having made 92 pitches he went five
innings gave up three runs on three hits
strikeout six walked one here is nikki
lopez he'll swing grounded to the left
side shortstop lindor has it goes to
second one onto first safe run comes in
to score and it's a one-run game
as reynolds comes home from third nikki
will get an rbi
and with his speed he keeps the inning
alive two out in the seventh
one one and a slider is pulled fair down
the left field line is going to roll all
the way to the fence nikki lopez flying
around second he's flying around third
here he comes home he scores on a double
by cam gallagher and the royals have
tied this game 5-5 cam gallagher his
fifth double on the year his third rbi
first and third you got a good guy up
here to hit
in the air center field that'll be deep
enough
the shields makes the play
and monday
singles steal second he goes to third on
a base hit and scores the go-ahead run
now another big hurdle for the royals
hitting with the bases loaded and he'll
take that so no hit with the bases
loaded but an rbi and the royals lead by
two in the eighth
a line shot into center field so franco
picks up dozier and merrifield's lead
off double turns into a run
and now the royals have scored five
unanswered runs
and they lead 8-5 in the night runners
at the corners not going to get a
fastball here
right chops it and it goes off the glove
of dozier therefield is there and they
get the out the indians get to run
closer it's eight to six
delano to shields is 0 for 3. the 1-2
swung on and missed he struck him out
and the royals win the ball game by a
final score of eight to six